I want to start with something kind of
funny today Steve Ducey is one of the
three hosts of The Fox News Morning Show
Fox and Friends and over the last 6 to
12 months occasionally Steve Ducey has
had these strange moments of clarity
where he will interject a fact or an
actually sort of interesting analysis
about a political situation usually his
hosts look kind of confused about the
fact that he's rather than
propagandizing just saying something
that's uncontroversially true and of
course we're left to speculate about
what's going on is it ducey's uh sort of
private little way of rebelling against
the disinformation spread on Fox and
Friends or is it just that he stumbled
across a fact which happens sometimes
very sporadically on Fox News who knows
these clips are from the decoding Fox
News Twitter account who does a really
good job in this clip talking about most
of these clips are related to the 2024
Republican primary which is increasingly
an interesting topic on Fox News because
Fox News is sort of trying to figure out
what is our position going to be are we
going to be overtly pro-trump or are we
going to be subtly pro-trump or are we
going to be subtly anti-trump in the
sense that we will not talk about Trump
the most or will we choose a particular
candidate other than Trump like DeSantis
or others to attach ourselves to and try
to really promote that candidate it's
not clear the direction Fox News will go
yet but
here is Steve Ducey stating something I
talked about on the Wednesday show which
is when you look at polling in May or
June of the year before the primary it's
very often not representative of who
ultimately wins and Steve Ducey actually
doing that analysis which is a smart
analysis and it's an appropriate one
that we should be doing which has not
been done on Fox News take a look and
his uh his co-hosts look visibly
confused
the first votes in the caucuses aren't
going to be until July or rather January
she said in May of 20 2007 Romney McCain
and Rudy were all in the top three and
Mike Huckabee was at zero percent but
Mike Huckabee went on to win the Iowa
caucuses and then in May 2015
it the top three were Walker Rubio and
Huckabee and Cruz and Trump who finished
one and two were not even at 10 percent
this is all true so so much can happen
in Iowa and one of the great things that
uh okay so this is absolutely correct
and the message here is a very simple
message the fact that Trump is so far
ahead today doesn't guarantee that Trump
will be the eventual Republican nominee
now it's great that Steve Ducey is
introducing some evidence into this
historical evidence that I also
introduced his data was specifically
from Iowa where I was talking more
generally at the same time it just so
happens that this time around the
circumstances are particularly uh
unprecedented in the sense that yes the
leader at this point in time isn't
always the eventual nominee but the
leader at this point in time also isn't
usually a former president and that is
what we have right now so so great for
Steve Ducey to bring these things up the
two people who said alongside him don't
seem to know one way or the other what's
going on here's another example Steve
Ducey points out correctly
that desantis's argument that he could
serve eight years if he wins in 2024
whereas Trump would immediately be a
lame duck is absolutely true and Steve
Ducey mentions that as well as a reason
that maybe Republicans do want to
consider someone other than Trump who
would on day one be a lame duck
interesting I'm not avoiding the punch
I'll address it but it's not going to be
my focus and by the way he's big into
eight years I'm gonna need more than
four years to fix this Donald Trump can
only do four right I need eight I'll get
you eight if you get me four I'll get
another four if you elect Donald Trump
he can't give you another four so that's
a legitimate uh tactic without
alienating the base you know the famous
thing is whoever beats Donald Trump you
have to beat him and get his voters if
you beat him and loses voters you can't
win but and Brian you make the point
that we were talking about it last week
if Ron DeSantis wins he get he can be he
can serve for two terms but by the
Constitution Donald Trump who's already
served one term can only do another so
on his first day he would be a lame duck
and that is one of the considerations
big donors have and the worry from a lot
of big donors is not only does if Donald
Trump won the Primary it's a real good
chance he would lose the White House but
also lose the house and that's one of
the problems but listen I mean it's a
pretty good analysis from Steve Ducey I
have to say It's actually kind of like
grounded in reality I have absolutely no
idea whether this is the sort of thing
that the Fox News audience even pays
attention to when they watch Fox and
Friends Fox and Friends is very much the
type of show that you kind of have on in
the background while you're I don't know
making breakfast or whatever whatever
Fox News Watchers do in the morning I
don't know that it's really getting
through to anyone and I don't even know
that Ducey is doing this specifically to
push people away from Trump and towards
Ron DeSantis but it is certainly a very
very interesting thing that we are
seeing also interesting is that some of
the fox hosts aren't thrilled with
Trump's attacks on his own former press
secretary Kaylee mcanany let's talk
about that next one of our sponsors
today is fume not everything in a bad
habit is wrong so instead of a drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad part from your habit fume is an
Innovative award-winning device that
does exactly that fume is not electronic
there's no Vapor or harmful chemicals
fume is just a delicious flavored air
that makes replacing your bad habit easy
your fume comes with an adjustable
airflow dial and is designed with
movable Parts which is great for
fidgeting which can be great for people
breaking bad habits look at what people
online are saying they weren't sure what
to expect but ended up loving the taste
and the feel stopping is something lots
of people put off because it's difficult
to do but switching to fume is easy and
enjoyable there's no reason that you
can't be the next fume success story
head on over to try fumed dot com and
use the code Pacman to save 10 percent
when you get the journey pack which
comes with the device and three flavors
the link is down below